jay welcome back early one f4
oh early bird oh
the bird puns are real i thought i would
start the stream
a bit differently and
not be on me chess but be
in photoshop um because i'm planning to
upload
let me move my mic planning to upload a
video tomorrow
half a year oh thanks so much
grandmaster vader subbing for six months
happy half anniversary
um so this is my photoshop layout
so i'm going to try and do like a
complete
photoshop of a youtube thumbnail
and then hopefully it works
if i run into issues maybe i'll have to
do it off stream but um anyway i played
the game a few days ago
or maybe i can switch back to yeah
so i played a game where it was a
budapest
and it was kind of a jerome
so i plan to post this to youtube
tomorrow
and i'll call it the jerome
gambit meets the budapest gambit
um and i i had an idea for a thumbnail
involving
this image and the idea is to like
photoshop the board
like the jerome on this hand and the
budapest on this hand
i was experimenting with this a little
bit earlier and
i think it'll be an interesting concept
i'll probably spend the next like 20
minutes
photoshopping and then
and then get to some chests how about
which one is god
which one should i make god the buddha
pastor the jerome probably jerome right
i think in the so in the stream that i
played the game i said
i've said jerome meets the budapest so
i'll probably want jerome to be this one
anyway so what i'm gonna do okay so i
have this image
um keyboard i have not really used
photoshop on this computer but hopefully
it works
so i just want to grab like this board
okay let's copy
and let's let me make sure the image
size is correct
pixels okay so 1280x720 this is standard
youtube size
we're going to paste this in
and basically what i want to do
is put
the
let's zoom in here
so make it so the so the uh the bishop
is over the king
like so or the uh the the bishop and
king are
will be visible on the hand i have to
rotate this
and then i'm going to mask it out so
that looks pretty good
um and then
see the best way to do this probably all
invisible to lay out the layer first and
i want to mask
is it this one yeah quick select
so i just want to select the hand
uh i think that's selected the whole
thing oops
space bar is giving me issues uh let's
deselect this little space
i assume okay this is a background so
let's alt
okay
i can always fine-tune this later but
then what i'll do
so i have the selection then i will mask
it
and then okay so now it's kind of the
jerome
now the opacity is at 50 um
there's a few ways to blend this uh
this is already looking interesting
i could put it back to a hundred
and then overlay
i'm gonna play around with the blending
but i'm gonna try and keep the blending
the same
i'd also add a drop shadow to
that other drop shadow to this
so it looks like the hand is like a bit
distant from the background
oops or outer outer glow could be
interesting too
um i'm gonna play around with this but
for now we'll add the drop shadow
make it a little bit more distinct
okay cool
yeah hello to more people if you're just
joining uh this is
this is a behind-the-scenes photoshop
uh photoshop session
i guess so i'm gonna do the same thing
for this hand but with the budapest
so i don't need to select the whole
board i'll just select
the center copy
let's go back let's paste this
and then so basically i want the knight
the pawn so basically
this area of the board visible on the
other hand
hey it's gassimo thanks for subbing
oh gifted by rookie mistakes thanks
rookie mistakes
um okay so i'm gonna do the same process
so i i'm a fan of keyboard shortcuts so
i press five
to make it is it bugging
yeah so five makes it fifty percent
opacity
and then i'm just gonna hover over
[Music]
probably okay ctrl t to rotate
or transform i want to make it as big as
possible
oh i should have included
ah wait maybe i can expand this
actually i i want this i don't want uh
the finger to be loose actually this is
still pretty this
should be pretty good maybe i can shift
it over
i think that's good okay and then i'll
make it invisible
i'll select was selection w
quick select to be on this later
so quick select is a nice tool in
photoshop to select
um basically the main subject so
that was really easy to select the the
hand there's no weird gaps
um i'll go back to this layer uh there's
a mask button
right here wait what
i just do oh that was the wrong layer
okay so this layer is selected so this
is the budapest layer
this was a jerome man
so i'll have budapest selected will mask
and now it's looking better
um now i can apply the same settings
to if i copy layer style
and paste
this is looking pretty godly
um how do i zoom
in there we go um
so there's these like rough edges
oops i might want to smooth them out
let's go back let's just go in here with
the brush
make the softness yeah
i know how important this will be but
see if this will fix anything
yeah just so white edges i'm gonna
just soften a little bit
this probably won't be too visible in
the like thumbnail size the thumbnail
will
will be pretty small
but uh
okay i'll zoom out yeah so the thumbnail
will usually look like this
on on youtube so we can very clearly see
that this is
uh this is basically signifying jerome
this is budapest um
i'll take feedback from the chat if if i
should do
much more i think i want to darken the
background a little bit
uh there's a few ways to do that
i'm gonna duplicate this white layer
move it to the top oops
which i just do this layer to the top
i'm gonna add a vignette
and filter the lens correction
[Music]
um let's make a nice vignette
and multiply
i might just select the the masks again
this and this
and then i can mask out the background
i probably want to soften this
select modify a feather
just feather the selection
[Music]
and then mask and invert
just want the hands to pop
that's kind of harsh
but it is popping you can lower the
opacity a little bit
so it's not too harsh
i could also there's so many things to
do i can add some uh
like some vibrance it curves
this would affect the whole image
i don't know i don't want to go
overboard i feel like more like more
simple is probably better
but uh that's a
little bit of a little bit of contrast
there
so there's there's a few other things i
can do with um
the blending
if i wanted to i could have the hands go
over
this and then
play around with the blending mode
so overlay so overlay just adds for the
adds like to the contrast
this is also interesting you like
lights
see what the yeah maybe of light opacity
anyway i'm liking this um
yeah it's hard to go like i'm i'm used
to playing chess and going back and
forth between the chat but photoshop
it's a different different animal so
anyway okay now
i'll try and catch up in the chat eric
should stream this
that's what i'm doing i am streaming
this this is my first one my first ever
photoshop streams
which resources did you use to learn
photoshop youtube youtube tutorials
um well i've
so i started learning photoshop in high
school
so
i've been photoshopping for probably
about a decade i used to
use uh linda linda.com at some good like
introductory courses but a lot of it is
just through
you're doing
um i do use lightroom lightroom is more
for photography
photoshop is more for like editing
um like photo manipulation basically
like photoshop's working so i might do
more of this in the future
if uh if people want me to
i might put this on youtube too like
behind the scenes thumbnail design
uh so if this goes on youtube i hope you
guys enjoyed this
i know it's a bit different than than
usual but
i am trying to to still experiment
with a new type of content
do i do thumbnails for youtubers uh
not really just for my own channel but
um
i did do a thumbnail maybe i'll i did a
thumbnail for a friend
who's also a streamer uh maybe i can
find it rook
was it rook sack carlson
unknowingly
so i have a friend who who put out a
youtube video
um
so i made this thumbnail for my friend
he's uh
i'll link i'll link the thing in the
chat
so he unknowingly beat magnus carlson
with a sick rook sacrifice
so this thumbnail is maybe kind of in
the style of what i do for my channel
people can check out the video in the
chat